हेलो एवरीवन एंड एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी
गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई
दे रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? बताइए।
जल्दी से चैट में बताइए सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है। हेलो सलमान हेलो उत्तम
अममान सिंह हेलो जगत गुरु जी हर हर महादेव
अमन सिंह एंड थैंक यू एवरीवन तो
वी आर लाइव तो जल्दी से क्लास ज्वाइन कर
लीजिए अभी दे आर ओनली एट स्टूडेंट जैसा कि
आप देख पा रहे हो और थोड़ा सा एक मिनट 1
मिनट के लिए वेट करते हैं आई होप कि आप
सबको मेरी क्लास पसंद आ रही होंगी सबको
अच्छा लग रहा होगा क्लासेस में सबको अच्छा
लग रहा है? क्लासेस अच्छी लग रही है? पसंद
आ रही है?
यह भी तो शुरुआत है। अगर मैं बोलूं तो आप
लोगों के लिए यह शुरुआत है। यह वह शुरुआत
है जो आपने कभी सोचा नहीं होगा। क्योंकि
डेफोनिक्स एकडमी इज द ओनली एकेडमी जो आपके
लिए ऐसी ऐसी चीजें डिलीवर करेगी जहां पर
आपको किसी भी प्लेटफार्म पर शायद आगे ना
जाने की जरूरत पड़े। आपको पैसे देने की ना
जरूरत पड़े क्योंकि आपकी वह चीजें जो एक
अरेंज वे में एक सीक्वेंस वे में एक
कंटेंट के रूप में
आपको यहां पर बहुत ही क्वालिटी के साथ
देखने को मिलेगी
क्योंकि डे बाय डे हम इंटरेस्ट बढ़ाते
रहेंगे। अभी डे 45 है हमारा जो क्लास नंबर
45 है और आज का जो टॉपिक है आप सबको पता
है कि हमारा विंडोज प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
के बारे में है तो यह थोड़ी सी शुरुआत है
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन की और धीरे-धीरे आपके
जो इंटरेस्ट है रिलेटेड टू द क्लासेस
बढ़ता जाएगा और जैसे-जैसे आपका इंटरेस्ट
बढ़ेगा और जैसे-जैसे आप इंटरेस्ट शो करोगे
जैसे-जैसे आप रिएक्शन शो करोगे, जैसे आप
रिएक्ट करोगे वीडियोस पर आपके जो कमेंट है
इन सब पे जो आप रिएक्ट करोगे वैसे-वैसे
मैं भी आपको क्या करने वाला हूं कंटेंट
डिलीवर करता रहूंगा। ओके उसी प्रकार से
मैं आपको कंटेंट डिलीवर करता रहूंगा।
ओके वैसे-वैसे मैं आपको कंटेंट डिलीवर
करता रहूंगा।
थैंक यू अगर अमन आपको ऐसा लगता है कि मेरे
साथ पढ़ने में बहुत अच्छा लगता है। हां,
एक चीज है आप सबके लिए कि मेरी एक
रिक्वेस्ट है अगर आपको सच में हमारी
क्लासेस से कुछ वैल्यू मिलती है। आपको
वैलएबल कंटेंट मिलता है और उसको कहीं पर
आप यूज़ कर पा रहे हो और चाहे किसी भी
इंटरव्यू में, किसी भी एग्जाम में कहीं पर
भी तो प्लीज हमसे शेयर जरूर करो कि आपको
आपने जो भी कंटेंट हमसे सीखा है, जो चीजें
आपने हमसे सीखी ने आपको सिखाया है, वह
आपको कहां पर काम आया। वह आपके कहां पर
काम आया? क्योंकि
इससे एक तो हमें मोटिवेशन मिलता है और एक
और बेनिफिट यह होगा कि जो बाकी स्टूडेंट्स
है ना उनको पता चलेगा कि यहां पर सच में
कोई वैल्यू डिलीवर की जा रही है ट्रेनर्स
के द्वारा। यहां पर टाइम पास नहीं करवाया
जाता स्टूडेंट्स का।
यहां पर ऐसा नहीं किया जाता कि वॉलपेपर पर
कुछ है और कंटेंट वही बताया जा रहा है जो
कभी पहले हुआ था।
एग्जांपल्स आप देख पाते हो YouTube
YouTube पर ऐसे बहुत सारे चैनल्स हैं जहां
पर आपको क्या होता है कि वॉलपेपर में लिख
दिया जाता है कि सोनसो चीज हैक हो गई और
जब उनकी जो आप वीडियोस उनकी पीपीटीज
देखोगे तो वो वो चीजें हैं जो कभी पहले
2017 16 में कभी उनके एग्जांपल्स रहे थे
तो फिर ऐसा क्यों शो करते हैं इंगेजमेंट
के लिए कि जस्ट अभी कुछ दिन पहले हुआ है
क्योंकि वो वो सब गुमराह करने के लिए किया
जाता है आप लोगों के साथ। तो
तो चलिए सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं। दे आर
24 स्टूडेंट्स। नो इशू। तो अभी
तो आप लोगों को मैंने बताया आप लोगों से
रिक्वेस्ट है अगर आप लोगों को सच में कोई
वैल्यू मिलती है तो प्लीज शेयर, लाइक,
सब्सक्राइब एंड कमेंट में जरूर बताइए।
बताइए आपको और आप लोगों के के लिए एक और
चीज है कि क्लास की फ्रीक्वेंसी मैं
धीरे-धीरे बढ़ाना स्टार्ट करूंगा अभी और
आपके जो धीरे-धीरे क्योंकि आपका इंटरेस्ट
थोड़ा सा मुझे लगा कि यू आर इंटरेस्टिंग
दैट्स व्हाई कि मैं क्लास की फ्रीक्वेंसी
धीरे-धीरे अभी बढ़ाना स्टार्ट करूंगा।
तो एक भी क्लास मत मिस मत करना। तो आज का
जो सेशन है हमारा उस पर चलते हैं ताकि आज
का सेशन हमारा प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन।
आज का जो सेशन हमारा है वह है प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन। सबको पता है पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन में देयर आर टोटल एट
स्टेप्स।
जिसमें से आपका जो फोर्थ स्टेप है वह है
आपका प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन। स्टेप नंबर वन
हम कवर कर चुके हैं। स्टेप नंबर टू और
थ्री भी हम कवर कर चुके हैं पहले वाली
क्लासेस में। तो अभी हम स्टेप नंबर फोर का
जो बेसिक्स देखना स्टार्ट करेंगे Windows
और Linux के लिए और जैसे-जैसे आपका
कॉन्फिडेंस बढ़ेगा वो कॉन्फिडेंस कौन
बढ़ाएगा? मैं बढ़ाऊंगा। तो जैसे-जैसे आपका
कॉन्फिडेंस बढ़ेगा क्लासेस के लिए और मुझे
लगेगा कि अभी आपके जो लेवल है वह बढ़ाना
चाहिए तो मैं आपका लेवल ऑटोमेटिकली बढ़ाना
स्टार्ट कर दूंगा। तो नाउ कम्स टू आवर
सिनेरियो
इफ यू हैव गेन एक्सेस टू अ विंडज सिस्टम
विद एलिवेटेड प्रिविलजेस और एंटी अथॉरिटी
सिस्टम प्रिविलजेस। कहने का मतलब क्या है?
कि अगर आपने विंडोज जो सिस्टम है जो
कंप्रोमाइज किया था जिस पर आपने इनिशियल
एक्सेस गेन किया था अगर वह एडमिन प्रिलजेस
के साथ है या एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम
प्रिलजेस के साथ है मतलब आपको जो एक्सेस
मिला उसको उसका एक्सेस आपको या तो रूट
यूज़र्स का एक्सेस मिला या आपको एडमिन
यूज़र्स का एक्सेस मिला या फिर हम बात करें
एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम्स का एक्सेस आपको
मिला डायरेक्टली आपके एक्सप्लॉयटेशन फेज
के दौरान उस केस में आपको क्या करना है?
आपका जो प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन फेज है, स्टेप
नंबर फोर पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन का स्टेप
नंबर फोर प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन है। उसको क्या
करना है? स्किप करना है। आपको प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन करने की जरूरत नहीं है। इस केस
में
अगर इफ यू गेन एक्सेस टू अ विंडोज सिस्टम
विदाउट एलिवेटेड प्रिलजेस इन दिस केस वी
इन दिस केस वी नीड टू परफॉर्म प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन फेज ऑफ पोस्ट एक्सप्लशन। इस केस
में हमें क्या करना है कि अगर
सिनेरियो यह है अगर आपको Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के ऊपर जो इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन मिला
है जो इनिशियल फुट होल्ड आपने किया जो
एक्सेस मिला है अगर वह एक्सेस एलिवेटेड
नहीं है उसके प्रिलजेस कम है एडमिन लेवल
के प्रिलजेस नहीं है उस केस में आपको क्या
करना है आपका जो प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन फेज है
उसको परफॉर्म करना है उसको परफॉर्म करना
है। नेक्स्ट अब सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट सवाल यह
है कि
हाउ टू आइडेंटिफाई विंडज़ प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन वनेबिलिटीज या दूसरा सवाल यह है
हाउ टू एलिवेट आवर प्रिलजेस आफ्टर वी हैव
गेन एक्सेस टू द सिस्टम
कि
सर हमें कैसे हम कैसे पता करें कि कौन सी
कमियां या जो वनेबिलिटीज हैं या
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हैं जिसे हम
अपने
राइट्स बढ़ा सकते हैं। जिनसे हम क्या कर
सकते हैं? अपना जो राइट्स का मतलब क्या है
कि हम अपने प्रिलिजेस बढ़ा सकते हैं। और
सेकंड जो क्वेश्चंस है कि और फिर कौन से
तरीके हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं जिससे हम अपने
जो प्रिलिजेस हैं उनको एलिवेट करेंगे।
मतलब कौन सी टेक्निक्स का हम यूज़ कर सकते
हैं अपनी जो प्रिलिजेस को बढ़ाने के लिए।
नाउ
फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन इज अ वेरी
कॉम्प्लिकेटेड स्टेप ऑफ द पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन फेज। प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन इज़ अ
वेरी कॉम्प्लिकेटेड स्टेप ऑफ द पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन फेज। सबसे पहली बात यही समझो
कि यह काम आपका आसान नहीं है क्योंकि
पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन फेज में यह सबसे
कॉम्प्लिकेटेड स्टेप होता है। एंड दिस इज
नॉट जस्ट लिमिटेड टू द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
बिकॉज़ इट डज़ नॉट मैटर वेदर यू आर
टारगेटिंग Windows और Linux और यह सिर्फ
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम तक ही सीमित नहीं
है। यह कांसेप्ट दोनों ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर
अप्लाई होता है। चाहे आपका Windows हो,
चाहे Linux हो, बस टेक्निक्स अलग हो सकती
है। हाउएवर
देयर आर ए लॉट ऑफ विलेज एस्केलेशन
टेक्निक्स अवेलेबल दैट यू कैन यूटिलाइज टू
एलिवेट योर विलेजेज।
हालांकि यह इसलिए
प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन के लिए बहुत सारे
टेक्निक्स अवेलेबल्स हैं। जैसे कि मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
वीक सर्विज हैं, अनपेड सॉफ्टवेयर्स हैं।
या हम बात करें शेड्यूल टास्क है, एक्सेस
कंट्रोल लिस्ट एसेट्रा जिनका यूज़ करके हम
क्या कर सकते हैं? अपने प्रिलजेस को बढ़ा
सकते हैं।
होल्ड ऑन गाइज़ मेरा माउस थोड़ा सा इशू
क्रिएट कर रहा है।
ओके नाउ कम्स टू व्हाट इज प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन?
अब प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन होता क्या है?
प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन इज द प्रोसेस ऑफ
एक्सप्लइटिंग वनेबिलिटीज और मिस
कॉन्फिगरेशन इन सिस्टम्स टू एलिवेट
प्रिलजेस फ्रॉम वन यूजर टू अनदर टिपिकली
टू ए यूजर विद एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव और रूट
एक्सेस ऑन ए सिस्टम
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन का मतलब है सिस्टम की
कमियों या उनकी जो मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हैं
उनका फायदा उठाना या उनका फायदा उठाकर
अपने करंट करंट यूज़र्स के जो राइट्स हैं
उनको ज्यादा पावरफुल यूज़र्स जैसे कि आपके
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स या रूट यूज़र्स में
कन्वर्ट करना। यह होता है आपका प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन। अगेन मैं रिपीट करता हूं कि जो
सिस्टम के अंदर जो भी कमियांज हैं या जो
भी मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है उनका फायदा उठाकर
जो करंट यूज़र्स है उसके राइट को कन्वर्ट
करना मोर पावरफुल यूज़र्स के राइट में। और
मोर जो मोर पावरफुल यूजर्स कौन से हैं? या
तो रूट यूज़र्स हैं Linux के लिए और या फिर
हम बात करें एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स
जो Windows के केस में एक एग्जांपल के तौर
पे समझते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल्स वी गेन
एक्सेस टू ए सिस्टम दैट इज कॉल्ड Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एंड वी रियलाइज द
प्रिलजेस दैट वी आर करली एक्सेसिंग आर
वेरी लिमिटेड। एग्जांपल के तौर पर आपने
क्या किया? Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर
एक्सेस गेन किया।
लेकिन हमें यहां पर जो राइट मिले वह बहुत
ही लिमिटेड राइट्स थे। ओके नाउ बिकॉज़ विद
विद दिस प्रिलजेस वी कैन नॉट डू डेटा
एक्सप्लेरेशन और पिवेटिंग एटसेट्रा ऑन दैट
टारगेट नेटवर्क।
इस लेवल पर हम बड़े टास्क नहीं कर सकते।
मतलब जो भी प्रिलजेस हमें मिले हैं जो
एग्जांपल्स में हमें लिमिटेड प्रिलजेस
मिले हैं लिमिटेड एक्सेस मिला है तो इस
केस में हम बड़े टास्क परफॉर्म नहीं कर
सकते जैसे कि सेंसिटिव डाटा को निकालना या
नेटवर्क में विवेट करना या दूसरे होस्ट को
टारगेट करना जैसी चीजें हम नहीं कर सकते
क्योंकि इसके लिए हमारे पास प्रिविलजेस
नहीं है। सो
टू परफॉर्म आवर टास्क और ऑपरेशन वी
रिक्वायर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव प्लेजेस एंड फॉर
दैट वी नीड टू एलिवेट माय करंट प्रिलजेस
टू एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव प्लेजेस। इसलिए अगर
हमें अपने फाइनल गोल को अचीव करना है तो
इसके लिए हमें एडमिन राइट्स चाहिए। इसीलिए
आपको अपने करंट यूज़र्स को एडमिन राइट तक
अपग्रेड करना पड़ेगा।
नाउ प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन इज अ वाइटल एलिमेंट
ऑफ द अटैक लाइफ साइकिल एंड इज ए मेजर
डिटरमिनेंट इन द ओवरऑल सक्सेस ऑफ ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट।
प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन अटैक लाइफ साइकिल का एक
कोर हिस्सा होता है। अब
कितना टेस्ट आपका सक्सेसफुल होगा काफी हद
तक आपका इसी स्टेप पे डिपेंड करता है।
ओके? जो भी टेस्ट आप परफॉर्म कर रहे हो
किसी भी टारगेट के ऊपर वह काफी हद तक आपके
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन फेज पे ही क्या करता
है? डिपेंड करता है। एंड आफ्टर गेनिंग एन
इनिशियल फुट ऑन अ टारगेट सिस्टम यू विल बी
रिक्वायर्ड टू एलिवेट योर प्रिलजेस इन
ऑर्डर टू परफॉर्म टास्क एंड फंक्शनिटी दैट
रिक्वायर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव प्रिलजेस।
इनिशियल फुट होल्ड मिलने के बाद जो भी काम
आप करना चाहते हो और अगर
वह काम करने के लिए आपको एडमिन राइट चाहिए
तो वह तभी पॉसिबल होगा जब आप अपने
प्रिविलेजेस को एलिवेट करोगे।
तब तक आप वह काम नहीं कर पाओगे जब तक आप
आपके जो प्रिविलजेस है उनको एलिवेट नहीं
करोगे। ठीक है? कहने का मतलब यह है कि अगर
आपको अपना टास्क परफॉर्म करने के लिए अगर
एडमिन लेवल के राइट्स चाहिए तो आपको करंट
यूजर से एडमिन लेवल के राइट तक क्या करना
पड़ेगा? एलिवेट करना पड़ेगा। अपने
प्रिलजेस को शिफ्ट करना पड़ेगा। ओके? देंस
ऑफ प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन इन द पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग प्रोसेस कैन नॉट बी ओवरस्टेटेड
और ओवरलुक्ड।
अभी जो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन की जोेंस है
उन उसको हल्का समझने की गलती करना बहुत
बड़ी मिस्टेक होगी क्योंकि उसको कभी भी
हल्के में मत लेना। अदरवाइज क्या होगा? यह
आपकी लाइफ की सबसे बड़ी गलती हो सकती है
इन केस ऑफ साइबर सिक्योरिटी। बिकॉज़
क्योंकि जो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन का जो
स्टेप्स है आपको दिखने में लगता है छोटा
है बट यह स्टेप छोटा नहीं है क्योंकि
आपकी जो पूरी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की जो
लाइफ साइकिल है या जो आपकी पूरी
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की जो प्रोसेस है उस
पे काफी बड़ा इफेक्ट
इसका होता है। ओके? पूरा इफेक्ट इसी का ही
होता है। एंड डेवलपिंग योर प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन स्किल्स विल मार्क यू आउट एज ए
गुड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स। अगर आप
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन को अच्छे तरीके से
सीख लेते हो तो आप एक अच्छे पेन टेस्टर बन
सकते हो क्योंकि यह स्किल अपने आप में
काफी हाई वैल्यू स्किल है। इस स्किल की जो
वैल्यू है काफी हाई वैल्यू है बाकी सारी
स्किल से। एंड दिस इज द मोस्टेंट स्किल
फॉर एनी पेंट्रेशन टेस्टर्स इन द साइबर
सिक्योरिटी वर्ल्ड। ओके?
अगर आपको साइबर सिक्योरिटीज फील्ड में
क्या करना है? अगर सर्वाइव करना है या
साइबर सिक्योरिटी आपको पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग करनी है तो आपके पास पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन में प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन की
जो
[संगीत]
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन की क्या बोले कि जो
स्किल है वह आपके पास होनी
इंपॉर्टेंट है। ओके? काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है।
इस स्किल के बिना आप आपकी जो पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग की जो लाइफ साइकिल है या
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की जो जर्नी है वह
इनकंप्लीट है। यह मैं कहना चाहूंगा। ओके?
नाउ
नेक्स्ट हाउ टू आइडेंटिफाई विंडोज प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन वनेबिलिटीज? अब सबसे प्रैक्टिकल
सवाल यह है कि हम कैसे आइडेंटिफाई करें?
इन ऑर्डर टू एलिवेट योर प्रिलजेस ऑन
विंडोज यू मस्ट फर्स्ट आइडेंटिफाई प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन वबिलिटीज दैट एकिस्ट ऑन द
टारगेट सिस्टम।
पहला काम है सिस्टम के स्कैनिंग और
एनुमरेशन और उससे यह आईडिया लगाना कि
कौन-कौन सी मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हैं। कौन-कौन
से ओल्ड पैचेस हैं। वीक एक्सेस कंट्रोल
लिस्ट के बारे में फाइंड आउट करना।
कौन-कौन सी सर्विज वनेबल है, कौन-कौन सी
फाइल्स परमिशंस आपकी अनसेफ है। एसेट्रा यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस आपके लिए काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है। यह चीज आइडेंटिफाई करना
प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन के लिए। द ओनली फेज ऑफ़
प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन दैट रिमेन फिक्स्ड दैट
इज द प्रोसेस ऑफ आइडेंटिफाइंग प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन वनेबिलिटी।
ओके?
मतलब क्या है? इसका मतलब यह है कि
एक ही फेज इसमें फिक्स रहता है प्रिज
प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन में कि प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन वनेबिलिटीज को आइडेंटिफाई करने
की प्रोसेस यह फिक्स रहती है। यह क्या
रहती है आपकी? फिक्स रहती है। आफ्टर दीज़
टूल्स एंड टेक्निक्स आफ्टर दीज़ इसके बाद
टूल्स एंड टेक्निक्स दैट यू विल यूज़ टू
एलिवेट योर प्लेजेस विल डिपेंड ऑन ए लॉट
ऑफ़ फैक्टर्स। फॉर एग्जांपल्स वर्जन ऑफ
Windows एंड सिस्टम्स यूनिक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
एटसेट्रा। इसके बाद जो भी टूल्स और
टेक्निक्स यूज की जाती हैं प्रिलजेस को
एलिवेट करने के लिए वो बहुत सारे फैक्टर्स
पे डिपेंड करती है। जैसे कि कौन सा वर्जन
होगा Windows का? कौन-कौन सी यूनिक
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है किसी भी सिस्टम्स की। ऐसे
बहुत सारे फैक्टर्स पे क्या करती है? वह
डिपेंड करती है। या हम बात करें पैच लेवल
क्या है? कौन-कौन से सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल्ड
हैं? कौन-कौन सी सर्विज रन कर रही हैं या
कोई स्पेसिफिक स्पेशल कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है या
नहीं है। यह सारी चीजें आपके क्या करती
है? यह सारे फैक्टर्स डिपेंड करते हैं
आपके प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन के लिए। दिस
प्रोसेस कैन बी क्विट टीडीएस एंड टाइम
कंज्यूमिंग एंड एज अ रिजल्ट इट इज़
रिकमेंडेड टू ऑटोमेट द प्रोसेस ऑफ़
आइडेंटिफाइंग प्रिज एस्केलेशन
वलनेबिलिटीज। अभी जो यह प्रोसेस है जो
आपकी जो मैनुअल एनुमरेशन की जो प्रोसेस है
वो आप मैं मानता हूं कि काफी बोरिंग और
टाइम कंज्यूमिंग हो सकती है। इसलिए आपको
क्या करना है? आप अपनी ऑटोमेशन प्रोसेस का
यूज कर सकते हो।
प्लेज एस्केलेशन की वनेबिलिटीज को
आइडेंटिफाई करने के लिए ताकि आपसे गलतियां
कम हो या कुछ चीजें आपसे छूट ना जाए। खास
करके जिस पे आपका ध्यान ना जाए। एंड दिस
कैन बी डन थ्रू द यूज़ ऑफ वेरियस ऑटोमेशन
स्क्रिप्ट। वैसे तो यह काम करने के लिए
बहुत सारे स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल्स हैं। लेकिन
वन ऑफ द मोस्ट पॉपुलर में हम बात करने
वाले हैं। वन ऑफ द बेस्ट स्क्रिप्ट फॉर
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन चेक इज प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन चेक। यह एक पावर सेल स्क्रिप्ट
है जो काफी पॉपुलर है। इसका ज्यादातर यूज़
किया जाता है। दिस स्क्रिप्ट एम टू
एनुमरेट कॉमन Windows कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस।
इश्यूज दैट कैन बी लवरेज फॉर लोकल
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
ओके लोकल प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन अभी जो ये
स्क्रिप्ट है यह कुछ बेसिक चेक परफॉर्म
करती है जैसे कि वीक सर्विस परमिशंस
राइटबल एग्जीक्यूटबल्स
अनकोटेड सर्विस पाथ शेड्यूल टास्क वीक
रजिस्ट्री परमिशंस जो किसी भी लोकल प्लेस
एस्केलेशन के काम आ सकती हैं। एंड इट
आल्सो गैदर वेरियस इंफॉर्मेशन दैट माइट बी
यूज़फुल फॉर एक्सप्लइटेशन एंड पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन। साथ के साथ और भी यूज़फुल
डाटा कलेक्ट करती है। जैसे कि जो
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल्ड है उनके वर्जन कौन से
हैं? हॉट फिक्सेस की इंफॉर्मेशन, नेटवर्क
कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस की इंफॉर्मेशन या कोई भी
रनिंग प्रोसेससेस है उनके बारे में भी
इंफॉर्मेशन यह कलेक्ट करती है जो आपके
एक्सप्लइटेशन और पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन में
की जो प्लानिंग में काफी हेल्प करते हैं।
तो अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन कि प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन होता क्या है? और सबसे पहली जो
स्क्रिप्ट है जो सबसे पहले जो हम टूल बोल
सकते हैं प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन को आइडेंटिफाई
करने के लिए हम उसका अभी प्रैक्टिकल यूज़
देखेंगे।
ओके एवरीवन क्लियर यहां तक सबको समझ में आ
रहा है? इंटरेस्टिंग एवरीवन
यहां पर किसके लिए चीज नहीं थी? बताइए।
किस-किस के लिए यह चीज नहीं थी?
बस ओनली तीन स्टूडेंट के लिए नहीं थी।
ओनली तीन ही स्टूडेंट्स के लिए नहीं थी
क्या यह चीज?
देखो मैं नहीं है आपको नहीं है जो
स्क्रिप्ट और टूल्स रन करके दिखाता हूं तो
उसके बाद क्या होता है कि आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी होती है कि उसके ऊपर आप
खुद से अपने नोट्स बना के रखें क्योंकि
किसी भी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग में आपके
काफी हेल्पफुल होंगे क्योंकि आपके खुद के
नोट्स काफी हेल्पफुल होंगे। समझ में आ गई?
जैसे कि प्रिलिज एस्केलेशन चेकक्स है। यह
चीज मैं परफॉर्म करके दिखा दूंगा। अभी
मेरे पास इसके लिए कोई लैब नहीं है। बट
मैं अपनी खुद की एक Windows सर्वर 2019
में इसको परफॉर्म करके दिखाऊंगा जिसमें
वनेबिलिटीज़ तो है नहीं। बट दिखाऊंगा कि
क्या-क्या चेक परफॉर्म करता है। जब आप
किसी वनेबल मशीन पर ये चेकक्स परफॉर्म
करोगे तो आपको ज्यादा चीजें क्लियर होंगी
कि कौन-कौन सी चीजें ये परफॉर्म करके
कौन-कौन से आउटपुट शो करता है। ओके?
चलिए तो हम चलते हैं प्रैक्टिकल सेशन पर।
तो अभी जो प्रैक्टिकल सेशन है मैं परफॉर्म
करने वाला हूं। जैसे कि अभी एक रिमोट
डेस्कटॉप कनेक्शन मैं कनेक्ट करता हूं।
ठीक है।
यह मेरा Windows सर्वर 2019 है। डाटा
सेंटर एवोलशंस तो यह प्रैक्टिस के लिए है।
तो आज हम यही देखने वाले हैं। ओके गाइस
यही चीज हम देखने वाले हैं। तो एक काम
करते हैं। तो जो चीज मैं आपको दिखाने वाला
था तो अभी ये क्या मेरे पास वनेबल मशीन
नहीं है। मैं जस्ट आपको शो कर देता हूं कि
वो टूल्स कैसे यूज़ हो रहे हैं। कंडीशंस जो
सिनेरियो मैंने आपको बताया था। इनका यूज़
तब करना है जब आप इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन कर
लेते हो उस मशीन के अंदर।
ओके? समझ में आ रहा है? जब आप इनिशियल अब
मैं अस्यूम कर रहा हूं कि आपने क्या किया?
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर चाहे वो
Windows सर्वर है, चाहे Windows 10 है,
Windows 8 है, Windows 7 है, Windows 11
है। आपने क्या किया? उसको कॉम्प्रोमाइज
किया। कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने के बाद आपने
इनिशियल फुटहोल्ड या इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन
किया। अब हम ऐसी कंडीशंस पे है कि हमने
क्या किया? इनिशियली एक्सेस कर लिया। हमने
क्या कर लिया? इनिशियली एक्सेस कर लिया।
उसके बाद हम कैसे इसका यूज़ कर सकते हैं?
उसके बाद हम इसको कैसे यूज़ कर सकते हैं?
ये चीज मैं आपको बताना चाहता हूं। अभी
मेरे पास ऐसा कोई इनिशियल एक्सेस वाला
एग्जांपल आपको शो नहीं किया है। क्योंकि
आपको पता है कि लास्ट क्लास में हम ऑलरेडी
एक स्टील माउंटेन की जो लैब थी उसको
कंटिन्यू कर रहे थे। तो आप उस पे कर सकते
हो ये चेक। यह चेक आप उस पे परफॉर्म करके
देख सकते हो। बट मैं आज आपको कांसेप्ट
दिखा रहा हूं कि कांसेप्ट में आपको कैसे
यूज़ करना है। और उसके लिए आपके पास स्किल
कौन सी होनी चाहिए? स्टेप नंबर टू और थ्री
मतलब स्टेप नंबर टू थ्री। थ्री है सेल
अपग्रेड करना। कौन से वाला? तो मैं इसकी
बात कर रहा हूं। कोई इस अलग स्टेप की बात
नहीं कर रहा। जब स्टेप नंबर टू और थ्री की
बात करूं तो यह थे जो हमने एक्सप्लेन किए
थे। स्टेप नंबर टू और थ्री। स्टेप नंबर टू
ये थ्री। देखो देख पा रहे हो ट्रांसफरिंग
फाइल्स तो फाइल को कैसे ट्रांसफर कर सकते
हो आप Linux से Windows Windows से Linux
पर सर्वर सेटअप करके ये सारी चीज मैंने
आपको पहले सिखा चुका हूं कि Python सर्वर
इस्टैब्लिश करके उसके बाद फाइल को
ट्रांसफर कर सकते हो। तो अब Windows पे भी
आप ऐसा काम कर सकते हो। ओके? तो अभी के
लिए हम एक काम करते हैं। अगर ऐसा सिनेरियो
क्रिएट करना है तो मैं वह भी कर सकता हूं।
बट आप बताइए वह कैसे करना है?
मैं आपको रन करके दिखा दूं या फिर ऐसा
सिनेरियो चाहिए आप लोगों को और जो हम
स्क्रिप्ट यूज करने वाले हैं वह आपकी
प्रीवियस एस्केलेशन चेक यह रहा हम यूज़
करने वाले यह रही ghub रिपोजिटरी यह रहा
और इसी को हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं। मैं इसका
लिंक आपको प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं। देखिए आप
लोग बताइए क्या चाहिए आप लोगों को?
यह रहा आपका लिंक आपके इस स्क्रिप्ट का
पावर स्केल स्क्रिप्ट का। ओके। तो, अभी के
लिए मैंने क्या किया है? स्क्रिप्ट को
डाउनलोड किया है। क्योंकि आप क्या कर सकते
हो? इसको यहां से डाउनलोड कर सकते हो।
यहां पर जाओगे रिलीज के अंदर। रिलीज़ पे
जाओगे और इसको यहां पर क्या कर सकते हो?
प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन चेक.ps1 इसको जैसे
क्लिक करोगे डाउनलोड करो Linux के अंदर।
क्योंकि Windows का जो डिफेंडर्स है इसको
ब्लॉक कर देता है। फिर आपको अलऊ करना
पड़ेगा। हमने क्या किया है अभी? यह जो
स्क्रिप्ट है इस स्क्रिप्ट को हमने यहां
पर भी अभी ट्रांसफर कर लिया है। प्रिविलज
एस्क्लेशन जो यह मेरे Windows सर्वर है।
जैसे मैं आपको दिखाऊं इसके जैसे सीएमडी
फॉर एग्जांपल हमने इनिशियल एक्सेस ले रखा
था। यह इनिशियल एक्सेस क्योंकि एडमिन लेवल
की है तो कोई नहीं। यह इनिशियल एक्सेस
इसको मैं ज़ूम कर देता हूं आप लोगों के
लिए। इसको मैं ज़ूम करने के लिए मुझे क्या
करना पड़ेगा? आप लोगों के लिए 1 मिनट।
एक्स एडिट
डिफॉल्ट प्रॉपर्टीज प्रॉपर्टीज में बफर
नंबर फोंट
फोंट साइज मैं अगर 24 करता हूं तो ओके करो
सबको दिखाई दे रहा है ओके 24 मैंने कर
दिया ये रहा सबको दिखाई दे रहा है चलिए तो
फॉर एग्जांपल अगर मैं क्या करता हूं
सिस्टम
इनफो सिस्टम मैंने इनफो किया देखिए इट विल
टेक टाइम हम सबसे पहले यही काम करते से
Windows लोकल एनुमरेशन बताइए।
मैं रन करके दिखा देता हूं। जब कभी आप लोग
बोलोगे सर हम सीटीएफ चैलेंज हम एक काम
करेंगे कि टॉप 30 सीटीएफ चैलेंज अभी
स्टार्ट करना स्टार्ट करते हैं। चैलेंज कि
बैक टू बैक सीटीएफ करेंगे। वहां पे सारे
टेक्निक्स ऑटोमेटिकली आ जाए। तो वो फिर
हमारे लिए अच्छा रहेगा। उस केस में क्या
है? आपके पास ये टेक्निक्स, टेिक्स और
टूल्स होंगे। बस आपको परफॉर्म करने होंगे।
देखो ये है Windows सर्वर 2019 डेटाबेस
सेंटर Microsoft वर्जन ये है Microsoft
कॉरपोरेशन स्टैंड अलोन सर्वर मल्टी
प्रोसेस फ्री ये रहा Windows यूज़र्स ये
इसकी ये सारी डिटेल्स हैं। तो आपको पता चल
गया। अभी मैं क्या करने वाला हूं? इस
स्क्रिप्ट को रन करके दिखा देता हूं। इस
स्क्रिप्ट को आपके सामने रन करके दिखा
देता हूं। क्योंकि आपको पता है ट्रांसफर
करना क्या है कि अगर आपने मैटर जो मैटर
प्रिंटर सेशन है उसका एक्सेस लिया है तो
आप क्या कर सकते हो?
डायरेक्टली अपलोड कर सकते हो। अदरवाइज
आपको क्या करना है कि आपके लinक्स मशीन के
अंदर मैंने जैसे आपको बताया था आपको
लinक्स मशीन के अंदर क्या करना है? इस
स्क्रिप्ट को डाउनलोड करना है। डाउनलोड
करके वहां पर Python सर्वर सेटअप करना है।
Python सर्वर सेटअप करके आप सर्ट यूutil
एक कमांड होती है। मैं एक बता देता हूं यह
Windows के अंदर।
यह रहा सर्ट यूटिल्स कमांड होती है विंडोज
के अंदर। ये रही कमांड लाइन प्रोग्राम
होता है। आप इसमें बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस होते
हैं। देखो बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस होते हैं।
इसमें एक ऑप्शंस भी होता है कि आप क्या कर
सकते हो कि सर्ट यूटिल्स हफन
एक होता है हफन
आई विल चेक। इसमें देख लेंगे हम
एग्जैक्टली नॉट रिमेंबर
तो ये मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं। एक
ऑप्शंस होता है हफन अह यूआरएल कैच। अह
इसकी कमांड जो रहती है नॉर्मल आपको बता
देता हूं कि ऐसे रहती है। देखो मैं लिख
देता हूं यहां पर कि सर्ट यूटिल
यूआरएल चेक कैचे उसके बाद hfन एफ के साथ
अगर आप देखोगे तो आपको पता चल जाएगा ऐसे।
कुछ इस तरीके से कमांड मैं बताता हूं। एक
मिनट 1 मिनट आई विल शो यू इन इस तरीके से
रहती है वो। यह रहा कमांड टाइप कर रहा
हूं। सर्ट यूटिल उसके बाद हफन
यूआरएल
छ उसके बाद hfन ऐप उसके बाद http देन आपके
उसका IPपी एड्रेस
आई लोकल आईपी एड्रेस उसके बाद पोर्ट नंबर
80 पे आप रन करते हो जैसे कि हमारी इधर
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम है
स्क्रिप्ट PS1 जो भी है PS1 उसके बाद आप
कहां यह तो आप क्या है कि वह लोकेशन है
जहां पर वो सर्वर के ऊपर होस्टेड है वो
स्क्रिप्ट दूसरा आपको क्या स्क्रिप्ट का
नाम क्या रखना है फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने रखा
कि टेस्ट डॉट पीs1 इस तरीके से और हिट
एंटर करूंगा तो आप क्या कर सकते हो वो
स्क्रिप्ट यहीं पर करंट डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर वो क्या हो जाएगी रन हो जाएगी मतलब
करंट जो फोल्डर्स होगा उसके अंदर डाउनलोड
हो जाएगी और विंडोज के केस में हमेशा क्या
करना है आपको टेम अभी ये क्या है कि अब ये
काम नहीं करेगा बिकॉज़ यहां पर कुछ है
नहीं। देखो ऑनलाइन यह इट विल चेक इसने कुछ
क्योंकि एरर दिखाया यहां पर क्योंकि ऐसा
कुछ अवेलेबल नहीं था। बट आपको क्या करना
है इधर? उसके अलावा Windows के अंदर आपको
क्या करना है कि एक डायरेक्टरी होती है
टेम डायरेक्टरी। Windows C लोकल डिस्क C
यूज़र्स यूजरनेम उसके बाद एक टेम
डायरेक्टरी। सिर्फ टाइम डायरेक्टर के अंदर
ही आपको क्या करना है या कहीं पर भी एक
टाइम डायरेक्टर के अंदर ही आपको स्क्रिप्ट
टेस्टेड स्क्रिप्ट या जो भी स्क्रिप्ट आप
परफॉर्म करना चाहते हो टारगेट के ऊपर वहां
पर इंस्टॉल करो या डाउनलोड करो डाउनलोड
करके उसके बाद रन करो समझ में आ गया सबको
यह चीज क्लियर जो मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश
कर रहा हूं सबको यह चीज क्लियर है
यह चीज सबको क्लियर है
बताओ। बिल्कुल। तो अभी मैं स्क्रिप्ट को
रन करके दिखाता हूं। स्क्रिप्ट को रन करने
का प्रोसेस भी यहां पर दिया हुआ है। क्या
है? प्रोसेस मैं आपको बताता हूं। देखो,
इसने बोला है आप यहां पर जाइए। कुछ भी अलग
से नहीं करना आपको। देखो, यह क्या है?
क्विकली आइडेंटिफाई कॉमन विंडोज
वनेबिलिटीज एंड कॉन्फ़िगरेशन इशज़ दैट आर
नॉट नेसेसरी कवर्ड बाय पब्लिक सिक्योरिटी
स्टैंडर्ड्स एंड कलेक्ट यूज़फुल
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन फॉर एक्सप्लइटेशन एंड पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन टास्क। सब कुछ यहां पर लिखा
है। और अभी ये देखिए यहां पर हम यूज़ करने
वाले हैं बेसिक चेकक्स ओनली। देखो आई वांट
टू नो इफ देयर इज़ एनी ऑब्वियस वे आई कैन
एक्सलेट माय प्रोलेजेस। आप ये यूज़ पावर
सेल हफन ईपी बायपास सी ये सेम। आपको इसको
क्या करो? कॉपी कीजिए। और मैं यहां पर अभी
रन करके दिखा देता हूं आपको। यहां कॉपी
कीजिए। और मैं यहां पर आपको क्या कर देता
हूं? अभी रन करके दिखा देता हूं। यह देखो
आपको रन करके पावर सेल ईपी बाईपास सी इस
तरीके से और मैं अभी रन करके दिखाता हूं।
इट विल टेक टाइम। ओके समथिंग समथिंग
प्रॉब्लम इज़ दैट। ओके क्योंकि यह
स्क्रिप्ट यहां पर अवेलेबल नहीं थी। तो
सीएलएस कर देते हैं और सीडी डेस्कटॉप
यह रहा। अभी यह रही हमारी स्क्रिप्ट। सबको
दिखाई दे रहा है स्क्रिप्ट। एक बार देख लो
ध्यान से और हिट एंटर।
इट विल टेक टाइम। नो इशू। 5 मिनट, 7 मिनट
जितना भी टाइम लेना है इसको लेने दीजिए।
देखिए अभी इसको हम समझते हैं। स्टार्टिंग
से देखते हैं क्योंकि बहुत सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन है इसके अंदर। बहुत सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन बहुत सारे चेक परफॉर्म किए हैं
इसने कि देखो बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग से देखते
हैं। डिस्क्रिप्शन के साथ यह बता रहा है
आपको। बहुत सारे चेक उसने परफॉर्म किए
हैं। चलो यह रहा कैटेगरी है रिकॉन यूजर
आईडी गेट इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट द करंट यूजर
नेम डोमेन नेम एंड इट्स एक्सेस टोकन
एसआईडी इंटीग्रिटी लेवल ऑथेंटिकेशन आईडी।
अब यह इंटीग्रिटी लेवल होता क्या है? इसका
स्पेशल टॉपिक आएगा हमारे पास यूजर एक्सेस
कंट्रोल बायपास। वह भी मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा
और काफी डीप में एक डीप लेवल आपको नॉलेज
प्रोवाइड करूंगा और मे बी आपका नेक्स्ट जो
सेशन है डे 46 या क्लास 46 आपका यूजर
एक्सेस यूजर अकाउंट कंट्रोल बायपास का जो
टॉपिक है वही टॉपिक है काफी डिटेल्ड
वीडियो है मतलब आपके के लिए बेस्ट वीडियो
रहेगा वो इंटरनेट पे नाउ यहां पे देखिए
नेम है एसआईडी है हाई मैंडेटरी एच हां हाई
एम एमएल है इसका हाई मैंडेटरी लेवल है।
सेशन आईडी वन है। टोकन आईडी ऑथेंटिकेशन
आईडी ओरिजिनल आईडी। उसके बाद देखो सोर्स
यूजर 32 नाउ स्टेटस इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
सीवियरिटी नन है अभी देखो सीवियरिटी बहुत
सारी इनेशन अभी देखो यहां पर कितने इस पे
यूज़र्स हैं देखो एवरीवन वेल नोन एसआईडी के
साथ देखो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर रिमोट यूज़र्स ये
रहा इंटरेक्टिव कंसोल लोग लोकल यह देखो
इतनी सारी इनेशन होगी सीवियरटी नन उसके
बाद देखो क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस इन
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स को चेक करा चेक वेदर
एनी एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स कंटेन सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन सच एज क्रेडेंशियल्स और
सीक्रेट्स। ओके? नोट दैट दिस चेकक्स फॉलो
ए कीवर्ड बेस्ड अप्रोच एंड दिस माइट नॉट
बी कंप्लीटली रिलायबल। स्टेटन कुछ भी नहीं
मिला। मतलब इसका कहने का मतलब क्या है? कि
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स के अंदर कहीं पर भी
सिस्टम के अंदर आपने कहीं पर पासवर्ड्स या
कोई सेंसिटिव इनेशन स्टोर कर रखी थी
कीवर्ड बेस्ड। तो, यह उसको क्या करता है?
फैच करता है। ऐसी कोई इनेशन अवेलेबल नहीं
थी। यहां पर आपको कुछ नहीं देखने को मिला।
अब ये प्रिविलजिलेशन देखने की कोशिश करता
है। गेट इंफॉर्मेशनेशन अबाउट थर्ड पार्टी
सर्विज। इट डज़ शो बाय पार्सिंग द टारगेट
एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स मेटाडेटा एंड चेकिंग वेदर
द पब्लिशर इज Microsoft। देखो एसएसएस
एजेंट ओपन एसएसएस ऑथेंटिकेशन एजेंट है। यह
देखो लोकल सिस्टम स्टार्ट मोड डिसेबल है।
तो यू कैन डू एनीथिंग क्योंकि डिसेबल ही
है ये। सिस्टम 32 ओपन एसएस एसएस एजेंट ये
अवेलेबल है। सीवियरटी नन देखो नेक्स्ट नॉन
वनेरेबल कर्नल ड्राइवर चेक वेदर नॉन
वनेरेबल कर्नल ड्राइवर्स आर इंस्टॉल्ड इट
डज शो बाय कंप्यूटिंग द फाइल हैस ऑफ ईच
ड्राइवर एंड कंपेयरिंग द वैल्यू अगेन द
लिस्ट वर्ल्ड बाय द इसके द्वारा। यहां पे
देखो यहां पे कुछ नहीं मिला इसको तो कुछ
नहीं है। छोड़ो। उसके बाद देखिए
क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस चेक वेदर देयर इज एनी
अनइंटेंडेड फाइल्स और वेदर दे कंटेन
क्लियर टैक्स क्रेडेंशियल्स कुछ भी नहीं
मिला अगला चेक क्या था क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस
का विन लॉगन के थ्रू विन लॉग इन यूटिलिटी
आपको पता है मैं आपको बताया था चेक वेदर द
विन लॉगन रजिस्ट्री की कंटेंस क्लियर
टेक्स्ट क्रेडेंशियल्स नो दैट एंट्रीज विद
एन एंप्टी पासवर्ड फील्ड एंड आर फिल्टर्ड
आउट नॉट वनेबल कुछ नहीं मिला ग्रुप
पॉलिसीज जीपीपी नॉट वनेबल
एसएससीएम नेटवर्क अकाउंट पे यहां पर देखो
चेक वेदर एससीएम एनए एनएए नेटवर्क एक्सेस
अकाउंट क्रेडेंशियल्स आर स्टर्ड इन द
डब्ल्यूएमआई रिपोजिटरी इफ सो द यूजरनेम
एंड पासवर्ड
डीपीएपीआई ब्लब्स आर रिटर्न एंड बट कैन
ओनली बी डीप यूजिंग अ सिस्टम शॉप यहां पर
भी नॉट वनेबल नॉट वनेबल कोई इनेशन नहीं
मिली नॉट वनेबल
अब यह देखो यहां पर क्या है एलएसए
प्रोटेक्शन चेक वेदर एलएस ए प्रोटेक्शन इज़
इनेबल्ड नोट दैट व्हेन एलएसए प्रोटेक्शन
इज़ इनेबल्ड एलसाईx रन एज ए प्रोटेक्टेड
प्रोसेस लाइट पीपीएल एंड दस कैन ओनली बी
एक्यूज़्ड बाय अदर प्रोटेक्टेड प्रोसेससेस
विद एन एलिवेशन और हायर प्रोटेक्शन मतलब
डिस्क्रिप्शन भी इसने काफी डिटेल्स में
दिया है। नाउ देखो करंट कंट्रोल सेट एलएसए
डाटा कुछ नहीं मिला मतलब नॉट इनेबल्ड
यह क्या है स्टेटस वनेबल सीवियरिटी लॉ है
यह देखो क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस क्रेडेंशियल
गार्ड है बेस है यहां पर कुछ है देखते हैं
यहां पर एचएम सॉफ्टवेयर पॉलिसी माय विंडोज
डिवाइस गार्ड नल नल नल क्रेडेंशियल गार्ड
इज़ नॉट कॉन्फ़िगर्ड फॉल्स फॉल्स
क्रेडेंशियल गार्ड नॉट कॉन्फ़िगर्ड क्रेडिट
गार्ड इज़ नॉट रनिंग ये चीज़ आपको खुद से
फाइंड आउट करनी पड़ेंगी देखो न इसमें कोई
भी डोमेन जॉइन नहीं है। इनिशियल एक्सेस
देखो बिट लॉकर चेक बाय द बिट लॉoकर इज़
इनेबल्ड ऑन द सिस्टम ड्राइव एंड रिक्वायर
ए सेकंड फैक्टर्स ऑफ ऑथेंटिकेशन पिन या
स्टार्टअप की नो दैट दिस चेक माइट यल्ड ए
फाल्स पॉजिटिव इफ थर्ड पार्टी ड्राइवर
यहां पर देखो
वार्निंग नॉट अ वर्क स्टेशन बिटल लॉक
कॉन्फ़िगर इरिलेवेंट
नॉट वनेबल यह देखो प्लेज एस्केलेशन एंटी
एलएलएम डाउनग्रेड बहुत कुछ देखो यहां पर
देख सकते हो चेक वेदर द मशीन इज वनेबल टू
एंटी एलएम डाउन डाउनग्रेड अटैक इफ सो ए
लोकल एंड रिमोट अटैकर कुड कैप्चर द
एंटीएलएम वी2 ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑफ द पीसी अकाउंट
एंड यह देखो यहां पर क्या है एंटीएलएम
रिक्वायर्ड 128 बिट इंक्रिप्शन जीरो जीरो
रिक्वायर अलव ऑल ट्रेड रिगार्ड नॉट
कॉन्फिगर नॉट कॉन्फिगर एंटी एंटीएलएम टू
है तो मतलब यह खुद बता भी रहा बताएगा कि
वनेबल है या नहीं लेटरल मूवमेंट के लिए भी
देखो नल नल यह देखो शायद इतनी डिटेल
इनेशंस है जो आप खुद से कभी नहीं कर पाते
गाइज़ कभी नहीं कर पाते ना आप यह सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन क्या पता भी कर पाते क्या यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आप खुद से कभी पता भी कर
पाते हैं खुद ही बताइए नहीं कर पाते आप
पता यह देखो
पॉइंट एंड प्रिंट बेस्ड कॉन्फ़िगरेशन को
चेक कर रहा है कि चेक वेदर द प्रिंट फुलर
सर्विस इज़ इनेबल्ड इफ द पॉइंट एंड प्रिंट
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन अलाउ नॉन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर
टू इंस्टॉल प्रिंटर ड्राइवर देखो
यह चेक करते हैं वैल्यू इसकी यह है डाटा
नल है इसके इसके अंदर कोई भी डाटा नहीं है
ना क्योंकि यह बिल्कुल फ्रेश मशीन है।
इसमें मैंने कुछ काम किया ही नहीं है।
देखो कुछ नहीं मिला है अभी तक हमें कुछ भी
नहीं है। ऐसा कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग हो देखो
यहां पर कॉम सर्वर की चीजें देखो ध्यान से
सिक्योरिटी अपडेट का देखो ये रहा हॉट
फिक्स तीन अपडेट सिक्योरिटी अपडेट
सिक्योरिटी अपडेट 2022 में ही हुआ है। 115
इंस्टॉलेशन हुआ है। वनेबल सिक्योरिटी
मीडियम वनेबल सिक्योरिटी मीडियम है।
एग्जीक्यूशन टाइम यह रहा देखो स्टेटस यह
रहा नाउ यूजर सेशन गेट इनेशन अबाउट द
करंटली लॉकडाउन यूज़र्स एंड नोट दैट इट
माइट बी पॉसिबल टू कैप्चर और लेड द
एंटीएलएम या करबस ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑफ द दोज़
यूज़र्स देखो सर्विसेस
यह रहा आरडीपी सेशन एक्टिव है जिससे हमने
कनेक्ट किया है कंसल कनेक्टेड है ठीक है
ना सीवियरिटी नन नीचे वाले की यह रहा तो
इसने क्या बताया प्लेज एस्केलेशन
अपडेट हिस्ट्री मीडियम क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस
पर कुछ नहीं हार्डनिंग लो है पहले से
प्रोटेक्शन लो है तो टू मतलब बहुत सारी और
भी इन अगर यह वलनेबल होती किसी भी वनेबल
विंडोज मशीन पे इसको रन करके देखना जिसमें
सच में वनेबिलिटीज है तो आपको और भी
ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिलती सबको
क्लियर है यह चीज यह चीज आप खुद से
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
यह अंकित भाई बात ऐसी है बदतमीजी मत करो
ग्रुप में
समझ में आया पढ़ना है तो पढ़ो
बदतमीजी मत करो ग्रुप में
यहां पर आपको
वार्निंग दे रहा हूं। ठीक है? यह बदतमीजी
मत करो इधर।
ना तो हम कमांड प्रम चला के हैकर लगे ना
लगे।
ठीक है? वो आपसे कोई कंसर्न नहीं है। आपको
पढ़ना है पढ़िए, जाना है जाइए।
क्योंकि तुम्हारे जैसों की औकात से बाहर
हैं चीजें। मैं बोलने लगूंगा ना तो फिर
तुम रो पड़ोगे।
चलिए गाइस यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
आई थिंक यहां तक सबको क्लियर है।
तो आगे नेक्स्ट सेशन पे चल। नेक्स्ट टॉपिक
पे चले।
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक पर चले बताओ।
देखो जल्दी से चैट में आंसर करो। प्रिलेज
एस्केलेशन चेक के जो आपकी जो स्क्रिप्ट है
जो मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन किया है सबके लिए
बिल्कुल क्लियर है। तो हम आगे बढ़ते हैं
फिर।
चलिए अभी नेक्स्ट चेक हम परफॉर्म करते हैं
Windows कर्नल एक्सप्लइट से रिलेटेड। जो
नेक्स्ट चेकक्स होता है हमारा वो हम
परफॉर्म करते हैं Windows कर्नल
एक्सप्लइटेशन से रिलेटेड। समझ में आ गया?
नेक्स्ट चेक हमारा क्या है? Windows कर्नल
एक्सप्लइट से रिलेटेड। देखो Windows कर्नल
एक्सप्लइट्स के लिए लैब्स बहुत रेयर
मिलेगी आप लोगों को। बट इन फ्यूचर्स कभी
हम पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहे होंगे। मतलब इन
फ्यूचर्स कभी भी कोई सीटीएफ परफॉर्म कर
रहे हो अगर वहां पर कर्नल एक्सप्लइट का
कोई भी सीटीएफ होगा तो डेफिनेटली आज मैं
आपको टेक्निक्स बता देता हूं और जैसे उसको
मौका मिलेगा हम प्रैक्टिकली भी कर लेंगे
बट आई विल शो यू कि कौन सा टूल्स हमें
यूज़ कर सकते हैं और उसको हम देख सकते
हैं। ओके तो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल्स
रहेगा। तो नेक्स्ट Windows कर्नल। ए कर्नल
इज ए कंप्यूटर प्रोग्राम दैट इज द कोर ऑफ
एन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एंड हैज़ कंप्लीट
कंट्रोल ओवर एव्री रिसोर्सेज एंड
हार्डवेयर ऑन ए सिस्टम। कर्नल को सिंपल
शब्दों में समझो कि यह आपके ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का दिल है। मतलब बहुत ही पावरफुल
प्रोग्राम जो सीपीू, मेमोरी, डिवाइस और
बाकी हार्डवेयर पे पूरा कंट्रोल रखता है।
जब भी कोई भी प्रोग्राम कुछ भी करता है
आपके सिस्टम के अंदर जैसे फाइल को रीड
करता है, नेटवर्क को यूज़ करता है या
मेमोरी को एलोकेट करता है। तो वो सारे काम
कर्नल के थ्रू ही होते हैं। क्योंकि कर्नल
ही सिस्टम रिसोर्सेज को मैनेज करता है।
मींस इट इज़ रिस्पांसिबल फॉर वेरियस पीसेस
ऑफ़ फंक्शनैलिटी लाइक इनपुट, आउटपुट
ऑपरेशन, अर्थमैटिक ऑपरेशंस, मेमोरी
मैनेजमेंट एटसेट्रा। इसका मतलब यह है कि
कर्नल आपके बहुत सारे जो कर्नल्स है आपका
किसी भी मशीन के अंदर वह बहुत सारे काम
करता है। इनपुट आउटपुट ऑपरेशन को हैंडल
करता है। मेमो प्रोसेस को शेड्यूल करना या
आपके लो लेवल अर्थमेटिक या सीपीू
इंस्ट्रक्शंस को क्या करना? कोऑर्डिनेट
करना। यह सारे काम क्या करता है? आपका
कर्नल करता है। तो एंड वी कैन से दैट इट
एक्ट एज ए ट्रांसलेशन लेयर बिटवीन
हार्डवेयर एंड द सॉफ्टवेयर एंड फैसिलिटेट
द कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन दोज़ टू लेयर्स। कहने
का मतलब क्या है? कि जो आपका हार्डवेयर है
और सॉफ्टवेयर है उसके बीच में एक
ट्रांसलेशन लेयर का काम करता है। और जो
दोनों लेयर्स हैं इनके बीच में
कम्युनिकेशन क्या करता है? एस्टैब्लिश
करता है। इन दोनों के बीच में कम्युनिकेशन
करवाता है। ओके? आप डायरेक्ट इंटैक्ट नहीं
कर सकते बट वि द हेल्प ऑफ ए कर्नल यू कैन
इंटैक्ट इट। नाउ Windows एंटर द कर्नल दैट
कम्स प्री पैकेज्ड विद ऑल वर्जन ऑफ़
Microsoft Windows एंड ऑपरेट्स एज ए
ट्रेडिशनल कर्नल विद ए फ्यू एक्सेप्शनंस
बेस्ड ऑन यूजर डिज़ फेलोसफी। देखो Windows
NT एक स्पेसिफिक कर्नल फैमिली है जो
स्पेशली Microsoft Windows जो स्पेशली
क्या है जो जितने भी Microsoft Windows के
जो मॉडर्न वर्जनंस हैं उनमें यूज किया
जाता है। पहले भी यूज़ किया जाता था अभी भी
यूज़ किया जाता है। मतलब ये स्पेशली
Microsoft Windows के लिए है। Windows NT
जो कर्नल जो फैमिली है। ठीक है? कर्नल
फैमिली है ये आपकी। यह एक ट्रेडिशनल कर्नल
डिजाइन फिलॉसफी को फॉलो करता है। लेकिन जो
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट की जो डिजाइन चॉइससेस थी जो
आपकी जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट है उसकी जो डिजाइन
बोले कि उसकी जो डिजाइन की जो
रिक्वायरमेंट थी उसके हिसाब से जो इसका जो
बिहेवियर है और जो उसका बिहेवियर और जो
एब्स्ट्रैक्शंस है वो उसके अंदर जो
एब्स्ट्रैक्शंस है वो भी थोड़े से अलग
हैं। इसलिए आप इस जो Windows एंटी कर्नल
जो फैमिली है इसके अंदर आपको कुछ Windows
स्पेसिफिक इंटरनल्स देखने को मिलेंगे। ठीक
है जो विंडो स्पेसिफिक काम के लिए ही इसको
डिजाइन किया गया है रिक अकॉर्डिंग टू द
यूजर डिजाइन रिक्वायरमेंट
नाउ
इट कंसिस्ट ऑफ टू मेन मोड्स ऑफ ऑपरेशन दैट
डिटरमाइन
एक्सेस टू सिस्टम रिसोर्सेज एंड हार्डवेयर
इसका मतलब क्या है कि Windows ने कर्नल और
यूजर प्रोग्राम्स के बीच में क्लियर
सेपरेशन किया है या जो Windows है क्या
करता है वो अपने जो यूज़र्स प्रोग्राम्स है
जो कर्नल्स है उसके बीच में क्लियर
सेपरेशन रखता है यह क्या करता है आपके दो
अलग-अलग मोड्स को यूज करता है जिससे एक
चीज क्लियर है जिससे एक चीज बोले तो एक
चीज क्लियर हो जाती है कि कौन सा सिस्टम
जो कौन सा मोड कौन से सिस्टम रिसोर्सेज तक
एक्सेस कर सकता है मतलब कितने लेवल तक
एक्सेस कर सकता है यह इन मोड से क्लियर हो
जाता
जो क्या है कि किसी भी सिक्योरिटी सेपरेशन
या स्टेबिलिटी के लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
स्टेप्स होता है किसी भी
एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर या किसी भी एक
मशीन के अंदर तो यह वही स्टेप्स है कि
इसने क्या किया कि जो आपका यूजर
प्रोग्राम्स और जो कर्नल्स है उनको क्या
कर दिया सेपरेट कर दिया और अलग-अलग मोड
में रखा जिससे क्या हुआ कि जो रिसोर्सेज
या जो एक्सेस है वह लिमिटेड हो गया। सबसे
पहले बात करते हैं यूजर मोड। प्रोग्राम्स
एंड सर्विज
प्रोग्राम्स एंड सर्विज रनिंग इन यूजर मोड
हैव लिमिटेड एक्सेस टू सिस्टम रिसोर्सेज
एंड फंसिलिटी। यूजर मोड का मतलब है कम
प्रिलजेस। जो आपकी जो भी नॉर्मल
एप्लीकेशनेशंस है और सर्विज हैं वो आपकी
यूजर मोड में ही क्या करती है? रन करती
हैं। जिससे बेनिफिट क्या है कि उनका
डायरेक्ट इंटरेक्शन हार्डवेयर या सेंसिटिव
जो सिस्टम्स एरिया है जो आपका जो सेंसिटिव
मेमोरी है वहां तक उनका डायरेक्ट एक्सेस
नहीं है। वहां तक उनको डायरेक्ट एक्सेस
होता ही नहीं लिमिटेड होता है। अगर
दूसरा केस अगर आपका जो यूजर मोड प्रोग्राम
है अगर वह क्रैश भी हो जाए इससे आपका जो
पूरा सिस्टम है उस पर कोई भी इफेक्ट नहीं
पड़ेगा।
इसलिए हम कह सकते हैं कि यह एक सेफर
एनवायरमेंट क्रिएट करता है किसी भी
ऑर्डिनरी प्रोग्राम्स के लिए। नाउ कर्नल
मोड की बात करें। कर्नल मोड हैज़ अनरिस्टिक
अनरिस्ट्रिक्टेड एक्सेस टू सिस्टम
रिसोर्सेज एंड फंक्शनैलिटी विद द एडेड
फंक्शनैलिटी ऑफ़ मैनेजिंग डिवाइसेस एंड
सिस्टम मेमोरी। अब बात करें कर्नल मोड की।
कर्नल मोड के पास क्या है? फुल पावर होती
है। मतलब अनरिस्ट्रिक्टेड एक्सेस टू
सिस्टम रिसोर्सेज एंड फंक्शन। मतलब कोई
रिस्ट्रिक्शन नहीं। इसी वजह से कर्नल मोड
में जो भी प्रोग्राम लिखे जाते हैं, जो भी
कोड किया जाता है, वह काफी केयरफुली लिखा
जाता है। उसको काफी केयरफुली क्या करता
है?
प्रोग्राम किया जाता है डेवलपर के द्वारा।
काफी केयरफुली उसको लिखा जाता है। क्योंकि
कोई भी छोटी सी बग या वनेबिलिटीज
डायरेक्टली क्या कर सकती है? आपके सिस्टम
को क्रैश कर सकती है या फिर आपके डाटा लॉस
का रीजन या आपके डाटा लॉस का कारण बन सकती
है। नाउ हाउ टू आइडेंटिफाई विंडोज कर्नल
वनेबिलिटीज।
अब सवाल यह आता है कि कर्नल वनेबिलिटीज को
कैसे पहचाने?
कर्नल एक्सप्लइट ऑन Windows विल टिपिकली
टारगेट वनेबिलिटीज इन द Windows कर्नल टू
एग्जीक्यूट आर्बिट्रेरी कोड इन ऑर्डर टू
रन प्लेस सिस्टम कमांड और टू ऑब्टेन ए
सिस्टम सेल।
जब भी कोई अटैकर कर्नल लेवल्स बग्स को
टारगेट करता है तो उनका मेन मोटिव होता है
कि हायर प्रिविलजेस को हासिल करना। मतलब
आर्बिट्रेरी कोड को कर्नल कॉन्टेक्स्ट में
रन करके सिस्टम के अंदर हाईएस्ट
प्रिविलजेस को गेन करना उनका यह मेन मोटो
होता है। क्योंकि अटैकर को पता है अगर
उसने
यहां पर प्रिविलजेस ले लिए तो उसके पास उस
सिस्टम के ऊपर सबसे ज्यादा पावरफुल एक्सेस
मिल जाता है। क्योंकि डायरेक्टली वो कर्नल
मोड में रन करता है और वहां पे उसको जो
एक्सेस मिलेगा वो आपको सिस्टम लेवल का
एक्सेस मिलेगा। कोई नॉर्मल एक्सेस नहीं
मिलेगा। इसलिए अगर Windows कर्नल के अंदर
कोई वनेबिलिटीज कोई भी बग मिलता है और
उसके अंदर आप कोड एग्जीक्यूट कर पा रहे हो
तो इसका इंपैक्ट बहुत ज्यादा सीवियर होता
है। एंड द प्रोसेस विल डिफर बेस्ड ऑन द
वर्जन ऑफ़ Windows बीइंग टारगेटेड एंड
कर्नल एक्सप्लइट बीइंग यूज्ड। अभी जो
प्रोसेस है यह डिपेंड करती है कि Windows
का कौन सा वर्जन यूज किया गया है। उसके
अंदर कौन सा कर्नल यूज किया। क्योंकि हर
एक Windows वर्जन के हिसाब से कर्नल
वर्जनंस भी अलग होते हैं। इसलिए जो
वनेबिलिटीज है उनका इफेक्ट भी वर्जन टू
वर्ज वर्जन क्या होता है? चेंज होता है।
इसलिए
किसी भी सिक्योरिटी रिसर्च के लिए वर्जन
स्पेसिफिक एनालिसिस काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है।
नाउ कर्नल एक्सप्लॉयटेशन इज इज नॉट ए
प्रिलज एस्केलेशन वेक्टर। हम बात करें जो
कर्नल एक्सप्लॉयटेशन है वह कोई प्रिविलज
एस्केलेशन वेक्टर नहीं है। बिकॉज़ वंस यू
स्टार्ट इंटक्टिंग वि द कर्नल देन देयर आर
मेनी चांसेस यू कैन कॉज सिस्टम क्रशेस एंड
क्सक्वेंटली लीड टू लॉस ऑफ़ डेटा। जैसा कि
मैंने आपको बताया कि जैसे ही आप कर्नल के
साथ इंटैक्ट करना स्टार्ट करते हो तो बहुत
सारे चांसेस होते हैं कि आपका सिस्टम या
तो क्रैश करे या फिर उसकी वजह से डाटा लॉस
हो जाए। नाउ
प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन ऑन विंडोज सिस्टम विल
टिपिकली फॉलो द फॉलोइंग मेटोलॉजी
कि अगर आप विंडोज कर्नल से रिलेटेड आप
प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन की वनबिलिटीज
आइडेंटिफाई करना चाहते हो तो आप बेसिकली
ये दो मेथोलॉजी जो आपकी दो ट्रिक्स है
इनहीं का यूज़ किया जाता है। पहला
आइडेंटिफाइंग कर्नल वनेबिलिटीज़ फॉर
स्पेसिफिक वर्जन ऑफ़ Windows दैट यू आर
ट्राइंग टू एलिवेट योर प्लेज़र। सबसे पहले
आपको यह फाइंड आउट करना है कि कौन सा
Windows का वर्जन यूज़ हो रहा है। उसके
अंदर कौन सा कर्नल वर्जन यूज़ हो रहा है।
उसका बिल्ड वर्जन, उसका सर्विस पे की सारी
चीज़। उसके बाद उसके स्पेसिफिक वर्जन के
अगेंस्ट आपको क्या करना है? उन वनबिलिटीज़
को फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करनी है। उस
पर्टिकुलर वर्जन स्पेसिफिक Windows के
कर्नल के वर्जन स्पेसिफिक। क्योंकि जो
आपका टारगेट है
उस टारगेट के आपने एक बार वर्जन
आइडेंटिफाई कर लिया Windows का वर्जन जैसे
सर्वर 2019 है उसके बाद उसका कर्नल वर्जन
आप आइडेंटिफाई उसके बाद उसके अगेंस्ट आप
क्या करोगे वनेबिलिटीज को चेक करोगे कोई
कर्नल वनेबिलिटीज अवेलेबल है या नहीं है
क्योंकि हो सकता है कि वो पैच नहीं किया
गया हो पर्टिकुलर वर्जन देन सेकंड स्टेप
क्या रहेगा डाउनलोडिंग कंपाइलिंग एंड
ट्रांसफरिंग कर्नल एक्सप्लर्ट ऑन द टारगेट
सिस्टम सबसेेंट है जब आपने एक बार उस
वनबिलिटी को आइडेंटिफाई कर लिया। उसके बाद
उस पर्टिकुलर एक्सप्लइट को डाउनलोड करना,
कंपाइल करना और उस कर्नल एक्सप्लइट को
क्या करना? टारगेट सिस्टम पे ट्रांसफर
करना इज़ द सेकंड मोस्टेंट स्टेप। एंड अगेन
दीज़ टू प्रोसेससेस विल डिफर बेस्ड ऑन द
वर्जन ऑफ़ Windows यू आर टारगेटिंग। अब ये
दोनों के दोनों प्रोसेस आपके
आपकी डिपेंड करती है कि Windows का कौन सा
वर्जन आप टारगेट कर रहे हो। यहां तक
क्लियर है गाइस? यहां तक सबको सब कुछ
क्लियर है?
यहां तक सबको सब कुछ क्लियर है गाइस। सबको
समझ में आ गया कि कर्नल क्या होता है और
कर्नल के बारे में थोड़ा सा इंट्रोडक्शन
था। मैं मैंने आपको क्या किया? ट्राई किया
है एक्सप्लेन करने की। सबको समझ में आ
गया।
जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स हैं, प्लीज
आंसर द क्वेश्चन।
प्लीज आंसर करने की कोशिश कीजिए।
तो पता चल गया।
नेक्स्ट
एक टूल है। एक Python का टूल है Windows
एक्सप्लइट सजेस्टर। एक Python बेस्ड टूल्स
है जो क्या करता है? कंपेयर ए टारगेट पैच
लेवल अगेंस्ट द Microsoft वनेबिलिटी
डेटाबेस इन ऑर्डर टू डिटेक्ट पोटेंशियल
मिसिंग पैचेस ऑन द टारगेट। इट आल्सो
नोटिफाई द यूजर इफ देयर आर पब्लिक
एक्सप्लइट्स एंड मेटाइट मॉड्यूल्स अवेलेबल
फॉर द मिसिंग ब्लू। बेसिकली एक Python में
डेवलप किया गया एक टूल है जिसका नाम है
Windows एक्सप्लइट सजेस्ट। वो क्या करता
है कि Microsoft की जितने भी वन का जो
डेटाबेस है उसके अगेंस्ट क्या करता है?
जितने भी मिसिंग पैचेस है उनको क्या करता
है? कंपेयर करता है और कंपेयर करके आपको
यह भी नोटिफाई करता है। यह भी बताता है कि
क्या उस पर्टिकुलर
जो आपने डिटेक्ट किया है पैच जो मिसिंग
पैच है उसके अगेंस्ट कोई पब्लिक एक्सप्लइट
अवेलेबल है या नहीं है। मतलब नहीं है तो
नॉट ऑफ एनए लिखा आएगा। अगर अवेलेबल तो
उसकी पूरी डिटेल लिखी आई है। या कोई
मेटास्प्लेट मॉड्यूल अवेलेबल है उस मिसिंग
पैच के अगेंस्ट। यह है। दूसरी क्या है?
Windows कर्नल एक्सपर्ट्स। मतलब जहां पर
क्या है कि Windows के एक्स जो कर्नल्स के
बेस पर कुछ सीवीज के बेस पर सॉर्ट किए हुए
कुछ ट्रस्टेड एक्सप्लइट ले अवेलेबल्स हैं
जो एक गेट रिपॉजिटरी है वहां पर ये
अवेलेबल्स हैं। अगर आपकी सीवीई आपने इस
टूल से जो आइडेंटिफाई किया अगर वो मैच
करता है यहां पर Windows कर्नल एक्सप्लोर
के अंदर तो आप डायरेक्टली उसको क्या कर
सकते हो? यूज़ कर सकते हो अपने टारगेट को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने के लिए। क्लियर है यहां
तक? यह चीज़ दोनों चीज़ क्लियर है? इसको मैं
प्रैक्टिकली आपको शो करता हूं। तो आपको
क्या करना है? आपको Windows एक्सप्लोर
सजेस्ट सर्च करना है।
Windows
एक्सप्लोर सजेस्टर
ये रहा। Windows एक्सप्लोर सजेस्ट। आपको
क्या करना है? यह वाला लिंक पे जाना है
क्योंकि यही काम करता है यह वाला। मैं
आपको क्लिक करता हूं कंट्रोल सी और यह भी
आपको भेज देता हूं।
यह रहा यह लिंक भी आपको मैंने प्रोवाइड कर
दिया और यह रहा बैक कीजिए नाउ। उसके बाद
आपको क्या करना है? यहां पर सब कुछ स्टेप
दिए हुए हैं। आपको क्या करना है? डाउनलोड
कैसे करना है इसको? इसको डाउनलोड कैसे
करना है, यूज़ कैसे करना है, सब कुछ मैं
आपको बताऊंगा। आपको क्या करना है?
आपको गेट क्लोन करना है। तो यह मेरा
यह आपको कैसा लगा डेस्कटॉप का वॉलपेपर
स्पेशली फॉर दिस बैच?
वुड यू लाइक गाइस?
सबको अच्छा लगा?
चलिए नेक्स्ट अभी आपको क्या करना है? हम
होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर अभी और हम क्या
करते हैं अभी?
हम हम तो तो हम क्या करते हैं अभी भैया?
चलो
यह रहा। तो यहां पर गिट क्लोन करते हैं
हम। गिट क्लोन करते हैं। यहां से https यह
डेप्थ वन के साथ कंट्रोल सी जैसे हम गिट
क्लोन करते हैं तो यहां पर पेस्ट करते
हैं। तो आपको क्या करना है? सूडो और
कंट्रोल शिफ्ट वी गेट क्लो सबको दिखाई दे
रहा है?
बिल्कुल सबको दिखाई दे रहा है। गेट क्लोन
करना है इस टूल को। यही टूल काम करेगा और
कोई टूल काम ही नहीं करेगा।
अरे यार सूडो करना है यार।
वेट
चलिए शुडो हिट एंटर
क्लोनिंग यह क्लोन कर रहा है अभी यहां पर
भी ओके हमने क्लोन कर लिया जब आपने एक बार
क्लोन कर लिया एक बार इसको हटाओ। देखो
Windows एक्सप्लइट सजेस्ट नेक्स्ट जनरेशन
इज अ टूल बेस्ड ऑन द आउटपुट ऑफ Windows
सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशनेशन यूटिलिटी। मतलब आप
क्या करते हो? जो सिस्टम इनफो कमांड रन
करते हो सीएमडी के अंदर उसका जो आउटपुट है
उसके बेस पे ये क्या करता है? आपको सजेस्ट
करता है। व्हिच प्रोवाइड द लिस्ट ऑफ़
वनेबिलिटीज़। द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इज़ वलनेबल
टू इंक्लूडिंग एनी एक्सप्लइट फॉर दीज़
वनेबिलिटीज़। एव्री ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम सिस्टम Windows
XP एंड Windows 11 तक का है। इसमें
इंक्लूड देयर Windows सर्वर
काउंटर पार्ट्स इज सपोर्टेड। ठीक है? मतलब
काफी अपडेटेड है यह। उसके बाद आपको क्या
करना है?
यह लिस्ट चेक करो आप। उसके बाद सीडी
करेंगे हम यहां पर डब्ल्यूईएस ये रहा।
इसके अंदर एंटर करना है। एलएस करोगे। यहां
पर आप देख पा रहे हो wesp
windows एक्सप्लोर सजेस्ट पाई देखते हैं
हम भी
डब्ल्यू ईएस
डॉट पाई उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है एक
बार एंटर करना है एंटर करने के बाद यह
इसकी हेल्प फाइल है पूरी ये इसकी हेल्प
फाइल है कैसे इसको यूज़ करना है अभी के लिए
मैं इसको अपडेट करता हूं अपडेट करने के
लिए हफन यू यूज़ कर सकते हो hfन hfन अपडेट
डाउनलोड लेट लेटेस्ट लिस्ट ऑफ सीवीज उसके
बाद हफन पी मैनुअली स्पेसिफाई इंस्टॉल्ड
पैचेस इन एडिशन टू द वन उसके बाद यह रहा
तो हम इसको क्या करते हैं अभी यह रहा हफन
यू अपडेट करते हैं यह सबसे पहला काम है
आपको यह सारा काम परफॉर्म करना ही है तो
आपको सूडो के साथ इसको रन करना है सूडो
उसके बाद क्योंकि अदरवाइज यह काम नहीं
करेगा क्योंकि इसको एडमिन लेवल के प्लेजेस
चाहिए हफन यू हिट एंटर नाउ देखिए यह अपडेट
करना स्टार्ट कर देगा उसके बाद क्योंकि
मेरे पास ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड अपडेटेड है।
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है? उसके बाद
आपको टारगेट मशीन के जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल यह
हमारी टारगेट मशीन थी और यह मेरा सीएमडी
है। तो अभी मैं सिस्टम इनफो कमांड चलता
हूं। चलाता हूं। सिस्टम इनफो
यह मेरी सिस्टम इंफो कमांड है। इसका जो भी
आउटपुट है, उस आउटपुट को क्या करना है?
आपको कॉपी करना है एक फाइल के अंदर। देखो,
यह मेरा है आउटपुट। होस्ट नेम है यह सब।
लिखो। यह भी काफी डिटेल आउटपुट आपको
प्रोवाइड करता है। देखो मैं यहां पर किया
यहां तक। चलो
कॉपी कर लिया इसको मैंने। जैसे इसको मैंने
कॉपी किया। अभी मैं क्या करता हूं? इसको
इसी आउटपुट के अगेंस्ट कंपेयर करता है। तो
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं? इधर एक फाइल के
अंदर सेव करता हूं। मेरे पास ऑलरेडी एक
आउटपुट था। बट मैं इसको अभी वो कर लेता
हूं। 13 sxt फाइल है।txt नाम से आपको सेव
करना है। मैं इसको ओपन करता हूं। कंट्रोल
ऑल इसको डिलीट करता हूं। कंट्रोल वी यहां
पर कंट्रोल shift v करता हूं। यहां पर
पेस्ट कर दिया। यह रहा। आप देख पाओगे।
इसको मैं अगर जूम करके दिखाऊं।
यहां पर ऐसे नहीं दिखेगा यह आपको। यह इसके
अंदर मैंने पेस्ट कर दिया। देखो यहां पर
अगर मैं आपको दिखाऊं, तो इसके अंदर मैंने
पेस्ट कर दिया। मैं इसको और भी ज़ूम करके
दिखाता हूं। यह पेस्ट हो गया हमारा। इसके
अंदर मैंने पेस्ट कर दिया। कंट्रोल s इसको
मैंने सेव कर दिया। सेव करके इसको क्लोज
कर दिया। इस फाइल को हम चेक करते हैं। अभी
इसको भी मैं क्लज़ कर देता हूं।
एलएस
अब यहां पर यह फाइल नहीं है। यह फाइल कहां
पर है? होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। यह फाइल
कहां पर है? मैं अभी बैक करूं तो cd यह
रहा एलs यहां पर ये फाइल आपकी sxt pwd यह
मेरी होम डायरेक्ट होम रेट उसके बाद यह
रहा। तो चलिए एक काम करते हैं। अभी फिर से
अपने इसके पास चलते हैं।
यहां पर आ गए। अभी मैं क्या करूंगा? इसको
रन करता हूं। Python स्क्रिप्ट को नॉट
पाई। उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है?
होम
रेट उसके बाद s.txt नाम से मैंने सेव किया
था और आपको क्या करना है? इसको एंटर कर
देना है। हिट एंटर इट विल टेक टाइम और
आपको डिटेल्ड आउटपुट शो करेगा। देखो ये
रहा। अभी इसने बता दिया कितना कंपेयर
किया। अब ये क्या करता है? देखो यहां पर
आपको हर चीज को चेक करना है। क्योंकि देखो
आपके फाइल में क्या था? आप यह फाइल
देखोगे, तो यहां पर क्या है? इसने तीन हॉट
फिक्सेस इंस्टॉल दिखाए हैं। बट यह क्या
करता है कि जितने भी डेटाबेस में अवेलेबल
है वह कंपेयर करता है। यह इसी के बेस पे
आपको रिजल्ट शो करेगा। इसी के बेस के
रिजल्ट ओके आपने तो इतने ही इंस्टॉल किए
बाकी का डाटा क्योंकि पूरा डिटेल डेटाबेस
तो आपके पास नहीं है अभी तक जितने भी
इंस्टॉल किए हैं तो बिल्कुल केयरफुली आप
किसी पर डाउट है तो क्रॉस चेक करना है
एक्सप्लइट मिलता है तो अच्छी बात है हम
स्टार्टिंग से चलते हैं इसमें देखो
बिल्कुल ऊपर चलते हैं स्टार्टिंग
स्टार्टिंग स्टार्टिंग नाउ गो ये रहा यहां
यहां से स्टार्ट करते हैं बिल्कुल काफी
डिटेल इंफॉर्मेशन है इसके अंदर भी आप
देखोगे मजा आ गया सबको आई होप
यह देखो Windows एक्सप्लइट सजेस्टर 1.05
यह इसका वर्जन है। सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
स्पेसिफाई ये इसका वो था सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी और ये देखो इसका यूसेज आप कैसे यूज़
कर सकते हो। अगर आप क्या कहना चाहते हो कि
लेटेस्ट एग्जांपल्स है डाउनलोड लेटेस्ट
डेफिनेशंस तो ऐसे यूज़ करोगे कमांड।
वनेबिलिटीज को डिटरमाइन करना चाहते हो तो
आप ऐसे यूज़ करोगे जो हमने यूज़ किया है।
डिटरमाइन वनेबिलिटीज यूजिंग द क्यूएफ
फाइल। यह आपको अभी समझ में नहीं आया।
एडवांस यूज़ है। डिटरमाइन वनेबिलिटीज एंड
आउटपुट टू एफएल किसी के अंदर सेव करना
चाहते हो। सीएसवी के फॉर्मेट डिटरमाइन
वनेबिलिटीज एक्सप्लसिटली स्पेसिफाइंग
केबीज टू रिड्यूस फाल्स पॉजिटिव
स्पेसिफिकली आप क्या कर सकते हो? किसी
पर्टिकुलर केबीज के अगेंस्ट क्योंकि केबीज
की फॉर्म में होता है इनका जो पैच लेवल
अगर उसके अगेंस्ट आप चेक करना चाहते हो
ऐसे भी चेक कर सकते हो कि यह चेक है कि
नहीं। उसके बाद ये सारे इसके यूसेज के
एग्जांपल। नाउ अभी देखते हैं इसका आउटपुट
जो इसने शो किया है। देखो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
Windows सर्वर 2019 जन बिल्ड वर्जन 17763
वर्जन है 1809 आर्किटेक्चर 64 बिट है
इंस्टॉल हॉट फिक्सेस ये हैं। तो यहां पर
देखिए ये रहा ये सब को कंपेयर कर रहा है।
देखो Windows बिट लॉocker एलिवेशन प्ले वन
T Windows सर्वर Windows नॉट एक्सप्लइट
मिला ही नहीं नॉट अवेलेबल तो मतलब कोई
एक्सप्लइट मिला तो नहीं हम चेक करते हैं
एक-एक करके यह देखो कोई एक फ्लैट मिला तो
नहीं है। केबी इज नॉट नॉट अवेलेबल। इसने
क्या किया कि जो हॉट फिक्सेस का जो रिजल्ट
था उसके बेस इसने बता दिया कि भाई यह भी
हॉट फिक्सेस आपके पास होने चाहिए थे जो
यहां पर इसमें मेंशन किए हैं। बट आपके में
तो नहीं है। इसने डिसाइड कर लिया क्रॉस
चेक कर लिया। बट जरूरी नहीं है कि क्योंकि
ऑलरेडी सारे सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशनेशन फाइल के
अंदर वो सारे हॉट फिक्सेस को तो शो नहीं
किया गया। जितने भी आपने आज तक इंस्टॉल
किए हैं वो चीज़ है यहां पर। तो यहां क्रॉस
चेक करनी है। नॉट एप्लीकेबल यहां नहीं है।
नॉट अवेलेबल सॉरी यह भी नॉट अवेलेबल नॉट
अवेलेबल सारी सीवीज के साथ इसने कंपेयर
किया। नॉट अवेलेबल नॉट अवेलेबल नॉट
अवेलेबल। देखो जितनी भी सीवीज है सबके साथ
नॉट अवेलेबल। कोई मिलती तो है नहीं मिलती।
ऐसा चेक करते हैं हम। देखो नॉट अवेलेबल
नॉट अवेलेबल नॉट अवेलेबल। चलो चलो चलो और
चेक करते हैं।
चेक करते हैं। आई होप सबको
चीजें क्लियर हो रही होंगी। सबको टूल्स के
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही होगी। कैसे
किस चीज को यूज करना है। आपको मैं डेमो
दिखा रहा हूं। यह नॉट अवेलेबल देखो यह
रहा। मतलब शायद क्योंकि इसमें मिलेगा ही
नहीं। पहली बात तो क्योंकि यह वन लेवल
नहीं है कर्नल लेवल के लिए। यह देखो देखो
देखो देखो
ना इसमें नॉट मतलब है ही नहीं। अभी यहां
पर इसमें नहीं मिलेगा। लिटरली आपको नहीं
मिलेगा। देखो हम इसको चेक कर रहे हैं। फिर
भी आपको कहीं दिखता है तो
बहुत ज्यादा एलिस्ट बहुत ज्यादा कितनी देर
तक देखोगे मतलब यहां पर नहीं है सात जहां
तक आप देखोगे देखो
तो यह लिस्ट आप क्रॉस चेक कर सकते हैं।
देखो यहां पर बहुत कुछ है जो हम आराम आराम
से चला रहे हैं। देखो
है ही नहीं यहां पर
क्योंकि बहुत बड़ी लिस्ट है यहां पर।
देखोगे पूरी बहुत बड़ी लिस्ट है। मैं ऊपर
से ड्रैग कर रहा हूं तब जाके लिस्ट है
पूरी।
पता नहीं इसमें कितने 2000 कितने इसने
कंपेयर किया है।
नीचे आ जाते हैं। अभी यह रहा यह देखो।
डिस्प्लेइंग 2472 वबिलिटी के साथ इसने
कंपेयर इसने बता दिया इतने मिसिंग पैचेस
हैं। 31 पैचेस मिसिंग है बट वी नीड टू
फाइंड आउट लेकिन किसी के लिए हमें
एक्सप्लइट तो नहीं मिला मतलब हो भी सकता
है नहीं भी हो सकता है। वी नीड टू रिकनर्म
इट क्योंकि और भी अभी यह अकेला टूल नहीं
है। और भी अलग टूल्स हैं। तो सबके रिजल्ट
को इसके साथ कंपेयर करो। उसके बाद एक
निष्कर्ष पे आप पहुंचो। सबको क्लियर है यह
चीजें? समझ में आ गया गाइज? इस टूल्स को
कैसे यूज करना है? सबको समझ में आ गया
बताइए। अगर आ गया तो अच्छी बात है। और
नहीं आया तो और भी बताइए मेरे को गाइज।
देयर ओनली एट स्टूडेंट। वाओ वेरी गुड।
सेवन
डेंजरस हो आप लोग यार।
चलिए भाई ये आज का सेशन इतना ही था। बताइए
अब
किसी का कोई डाउट है क्लास से रिलेटेड तो
पूछिए। अगर डाउट नहीं है तो बताइए। एनीवन
हैव एनी डाउट रिलेटेड टू द क्लास।
और यह थी आपका स्टार्टअप।
कैसा लगा आप लोगों को स्टार्टअप?
कैसा लगा आप लोगों का स्टार्टअप? अभी तो
बहुत कुछ आपको सीखना बचा हुआ है। बहुत
सारी चीजें हैं जो मैं आपको सिखाने वाला
हूं।
सलमान मैं एक चीज और ट्राई सोच रहा हूं कि
आप लोगों करने के लिए कि मीडियम आर्टिकल्स
पे ये सारी चीजें आपको अवेलेबल मिल जाए।
पैरेली आई एम डेवलपिंग द आर्टिकल्स एंड
एंड आई विल अपलोड एंड आई विल शेयर द लिंक।
बट उसके लिए मुझे जितने भी स्टूडेंट देखते
हो सारे के सारे उधर मेरे को फॉलो करोगे
और मेरे आर्टिकल्स को रीड करोगे उधर कुछ
कमेंट भी करना है मुझे भी बेनिफिट होना
चाहिए
हो जाएगा ये सबके लिए सब लोग करोगे ये चीज
इट्स ओके तो किसी को कोई डाउट है बताइए
अदरवाइज नो डाउट तो यह भी बताइए सेशन को
एंड करेंगे।
ऑलरेडी दो आर्टिकल्स इन प्रोग्रेस है।
अपलोड करने के बाद मैं क्या करूंगा आप
लोगों को नेक्स्ट सेशन में उनको शेयर कर
दूंगा। फिर उसके बाद वहां से कंटिन्यू आप
क्या करने लग जाना मेरे को शेयर करने लग
जाना।
बहुत कुछ होता है अरमान पटेल और अगर आप
लोगों का रिस्पांस अच्छा रहे तो यह सारी
चीजें भी हो सकता है कि मैं आपको पढ़ा दूं
YouTube पे
तो बताइए नेक्स्ट सेशन कब करना है
कल या परसों में एक सेशन लूंगा मैं आपका
100% लूंगा या तो कल लूंगा या परसों लूंगा
क्योंकि बीच में सबको पता है कि दिवाली इज
अवेलेबल। दिवाली आ रही है तो इन एडवांस
हैप्पी दिवाली सभी को और
दिवाली के लिए हम किसी को भी वो नहीं करने
वाले। किसी का भी कोई जो फेस्टिवल है
फेस्टिवल पे कोई क्लास नहीं लेंगे अभी को
क्योंकि एंजॉय करना भी बहुत जरूरी होता
है।
मैं आपको अनाउंसमेंट करवा दूंगा या तो कल
होगी। अनाउंसमेंट आपको 10:00 बजे तक मिल
जाएगी कल सुबह या तो कल होगी या फिर
परसों। लैपटॉप मिनिमम i7 लीजिए या i5
रखिए।
i5 लेटेस्ट जनरेशन i7 मिनिमम रखिए। फिर
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक यूजर अकाउंट कंट्रोल यूएस
बाईपास फ्रॉम जीरो टू एक मतलब आपको
बिल्कुल ऐसे बताऊंगा कि आपको कुछ नहीं पता
यूएस के बारे में उसके बाद बायपास करना भी
बताऊंगा और यूएस में जो टूल्स है जो मोस्ट
पॉपुलर टूल्स है उसको भी यूज़ करना
दिखाऊंगा बट उससे पहले आपका जो बेसिक
फंडामेंटल है यूएससी का वह मैं एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा
ओके अरमान
हैप्पी
ये मैं आपको आपको पता चल जाएगा
जल्दी पता चल जाएगा कल 11 10 या 11:00 बजे
तक आपको पता चल जाएगा
ऐसा ही समझिए
जब मैं फ्री में चीजें देता हूं तो
बिल्कुल दिल से देता हूं। मैं परवाह नहीं
करता। बस मुझे एक ही चीज चाहिए होती है आप
लोगों से कि
आप लोगों का प्यार आप लोग इसको ज्यादा से
ज्यादा स्प्रेड करो। ज्यादा से ज्यादा लोग
लोगों को बताओ कि भाई पैसे मत वेस्ट करो।
उन पैसों को बचाओ एडवांस चीजें सीखने के
लिए
क्योंकि बहुत जरूरी है और आज के टाइम में
मुझे इतना तो पता है कि पैसे सबके पास है।
ठीक है? बट उसको सही चीज के लिए यूज करो।
यह वह चैनल है जहां पर आपको हर एक चीज को
काफी अच्छे से बताया जाएगा। आपको एक लेवल
है। उसके लिए आपको कहीं पर भी पेड चीजों
के लिए नहीं पढ़ना पड़ेगा। मैंने आपको
बताया ना Windows पेन टेस्टिंग भी मैं अगर
इनवॉल्व कर रहा हूं। अभी आप लोगों ने
रिक्वेस्ट की थी Windows पेन टेस्टिंग भी
मैं पढ़ाऊंगा इसमें तो फिर आप लोगों के के
लिए बच क्या जाएगा?
तो इसलिए बताइए ज्यादा से ज्यादा
स्टूडेंट्स को अपने अगर आप कॉलेज में हो,
स्कूल में हो या आप अपने कहीं पे भी ऐसी
जगह पर रह रहे हो जहां पर लोगों को इसकी
अवेयरनेस नहीं है। यह हर एक स्टूडेंट की
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है। इस इसकी अवेयरनेस
बढ़ाना चाहे अपने आप खुद के Instagram पर
इसकी अवेयरनेस को बढ़ाओ मुझे सपोर्ट करो
जितना मेरे को सपोर्ट करोगे कमेंट करो
आपको जो भी बेनिफिट हो रहा है वो
डेफोनिक्स एकडमी के lindin चैनल पे उसको
टैग करके बताओ सबको कि इन्होंने यह पढ़ा
है और हमें इससे बेनिफिट हुआ
कंपेयर करके बताओ कि हमने यहां यहां से
पढ़ा है बट यहां यहां से पढ़ के हमें यह
बेनिफिट नहीं हुआ यहां से यह बेनिफिट हुआ
है। ज्यादा से ज्यादा लोगों को बताओ।
हां, लinक्स प्लेस्कशन अभी तक स्टार्ट ही
नहीं किया है। डोंट वरी वो भी करेंगे।
जो जो मैंने बोला सब कुछ करेंगे बट जो
मैंने आपको बोला आप लोग वो कीजिए। आपकी एक
ही रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है इसको इतना फैला दो
कि
सब
लोग जिनको सच में जरूरत है। लिटरली जिनको
कुछ सीखना है, अपने आपको एक एक्सपर्ट करना
है,
वह अपने आपको एक्सपर्ट कर पाए।
मैं गलत चीज के लिए एडवर्टाइज करने के लिए
नहीं बोल रहा क्योंकि आपको भी पता है यह
चीज सही है इसलिए मैं आपको एडवर्टाइज करने
के लिए बोल रहा हूं। अदरवाइज मैं आपको
बोलता ही नहीं।
अगर अगर आप लोगों को लगता है कि नहीं सर
यह सही नहीं है।
तो आप स्टूडेंट हो। आपको बिल्कुल
राइट है कि सही और गलत चूज करने का। कोई
आपको फोर्स नहीं कर सकता। ओके एवरीवन?
चलिए अगर आप लोगों को कोई भी डाउट नहीं है
और आप लोगों को अगर मेरी बातें समझ में आ
गई हैं और आप लोगों को सच में लगता है कि
सचिन सर को
[संगीत]
थोड़ा सा स्टूडेंट्स की तरफ से प्यार
मिलना चाहिए तो आप लोग दीजिए अच्छा रहेगा
अदरवाइज
डिपेंड्स ऑन यू माय डियर स्टूडेंट्स
ओके तो चलिए बाय-बाय गुड नाइट
अगर कोई भी डाउट है तो कमेंट सेक्शन में
आप अपना डाउट पूछिए। नेक्स्ट क्लास में
उसमें डिस्कस कर लेंगे। यह भी मैंने ओपन
चैनल रखा हुआ आप लोगों के लिए। ओके बाय-ब
गुड नाइट एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।
नेक्स्ट सेशन की अनाउंसमेंट आपको WhatsApp
चैनल पर मिल जाएगी। ओके बाय बाय। गुड नाइट
एवरीवन।